[Musique]
à vélo en roller ou encore à pied ce
week-end pour la cinquième édition du
slowup la route des vins d'alsace se
mettait au vert sous la ive
haut-koenigsbourg ce sont quarante mille
personnes qui ont pu profiter des cinq
parcours proposés pour découvrir les
neuf communes partenaires
evènement sport dégustations
gastronomiques étaient au programme
la philosophie c'est de faire venir chez
nous voilà le plus de monde possible
pour a pour à la fois apprécier le
paysage nos paysages profitait aussi de
nos excellents vins ici sur le sur le
secteur découvrir notre territoire d'une
autre façon que ce que nous faisons
habituellement c'est à dire en en
voiture ça fait connaître notre
territoire
moi je je sais que ma commune à bergheim
on est on est situé sur la route du vin
mais les voitures ont tendance à rester
sur la route et à ne pas rentrer dans le
village puisqu'il faut franchir la porte
est haute pour être pour être dans le
centre bourg ba aujourd'hui bas il y a
près de 40000 personnes qui vont
franchir la porte et au de bergheim qui
vont traverser la grand'rue et pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux qui vont
découvrir notre notre belle commune avec
lydia bien sûr c'est que c'est qu'on
leur donne envie de revenir après de
profiter de nos atouts et ils sont
nombreux bien sûr la gastronomie les
vins nous avons un patrimoine très
intéressant et aujourd'hui par exemple
nos restaurateurs vont faire pour faire
salle comble donc il ya aussi un intérêt
économique qui est lié à cette à cet
événement depuis 2013 cet événement qui
fut organisée pour le 60e anniversaire
de la route des vins entend faire la
promotion des modes de transports doux
ainsi la dernière ce sont 400 mille
kilomètres cumulés qui ont été parcourus
par les participants sans la moindre
émission de carbone
au delà de l'écocitoyenneté le slowup
organisé par alsace destination tourisme
avec la collaboration des deux
départements alsaciens est aussi une
formidable vitre
pour les territoires un événement
ludique qui rencontre un franc succès
c'est un vrai symbole du rapprochement
de nos deux départements du haut-rhin du
bas-rhin puisque nous sommes quatre
communes haut-rhinoises cinq communes
bas-rhinoises 1 qui coopéreront qui
organiseront ensemble cette ce bel
événement et nous sommes toujours très
heureux de nous retrouver lors des
réunions on se connaît très bien
maintenant et je crois que c'est
effectivement une belle réussite aussi à
ce niveau là le bilan est tout à fait
positif puisque en terme de
fréquentation nous avons démarré en 2013
avec quinze mille participants et
l'année dernière nous en étions à 37000
donc une fréquentation très progressive
mais importante et avec le soleil qui
est revenu aujourd'hui ce matin ben on
espère atteindre les 40 milles alors
bien sûr c'est une manifestation qui au
vu de cette fréquentation nécessite la
mise en place d'une organisation
importante près de 1000 bénévoles qui
s'investissent pour animer à la fois les
places festive mais aussi pour sécuriser
le parcours on délaisse le vélo pour les
poussettes nous sommes maintenant aux
abords de la station du lac blanc
si le secteur est prisé des randonneurs
les merveilles du paysage sont trop
souvent difficiles d'accès pour les
familles c'est ce qu'entend corriger ce
parcours poussette un circuit poussette
c'est vraiment un circuit adapté aux
familles pour découvrir de beaux
panoramas sur les lignes de crêtes
vosgiennes mais aussi la plaine d'alsace
et même partir à la découverte des
vestiges de la première guerre mondiale
puisque ce circuit traverse la forêt
jusqu'à la tête défaut non loin de la
tête défaut où on a des vestiges de
cette première guerre une initiative
menée sur l'ensemble du massif des
vosges aux commandes les départements 67
68 88
l'union européenne et les communes
concernées alors ce cirque pouces est en
fête a été développé dans le cadre du
contrat de destination massif des vosges
qui est
en partie financé par le conseil
départemental du haut rhin avec d'autres
partenaires financiers et qui vise en
fait à développer une offre touristique
de qualité et structures et lisible et
cohérente à l'échelle de l'ensemble du
massif
alors l'une des filières de ce contrat
c'est la filière massif des vosges en
famille qui a pour objectif de
structurer l'offre des stations de
montagne et de créer une offre de
qualité pour les publics famille et ce
sur les quatre saisons
on reste dans le massif sur les hauteurs
d'orbey à 900 mètres d'altitude on part
à la découverte de très anciens
pâturages d'altitude de ferme
montagnarde qui fabriquent encore du
fromage de munster avec à partir du lait
de vache de race vosgienne notamment
c'est un formidable terrain pour les
enfants puisqu'on à une balade qui est
tout à fait accessible avec un chemin
très praticable en famille et sur une
durée tout à fait raisonnable cette
balade fait partie des 21 une balade
famille du massif des vosges
alors il ya une carte qui regroupe
toutes ces balades puisque le massif des
vosges
regorge de sentiers nous avons 18 km 18
mille kilomètres de sentiers balisés un
paradis pour les randonneurs de tous les
âges une destination famille de premier
plan et dans les offices du tourisme et
bien on peut trouver cette carte est
allé à la découverte de l'une des ses
ventes et une balade
enfin nous descendons dans le vignoble
au pied du château de kaysersberg
s'étendent les vignes qui nous offre de
si bons crus ici aussi on peut se
balader en toute saison et à tout âge là
aussi un sentier balade accessible à
tous est proposée
l'idée c'est vraiment de se promener de
se promener dans les vignes de s'arrêter
2 pourquoi pas prendre un carnet de
croquis et d'inviter les enfants à
s'asseoir sur un petit muret dans les
vignes et puis de faire une petite un
petit dessin du paysage
l'idée c'est aussi et bien de s'arrêter
pique-niqué puisque cet itinéraire il
est jalonné de tables de pique nique et
puis l'idée c'est aussi de jouer puisque
on a une petite aire ludique au pied du
château avec des petites huttes où les
enfants peuvent jouer à cache cache et
c'est très très sympa quand on a des
enfants en bas âge enfin quelques images
du slowup pour terminer si la
vous démange
sachez que jusqu'au 18 juin c'est le
défi au boulot j'y vais à vélo